لانه واصل متابعه الملفات السودانيه حيث
قال مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي ان فشل
وقف اطلاق النار في السودان يزيد مخاوف
امريكا من صراع طويل الامد ومعاناه واسعه
النطاق لعرض الموقف الامريكي من هذه
التطورات في السودان معنى الامن واشنطن
مراسل الجزيره ناصر الحسين اذا نرحب بك من
جديد ناصر وكنت تتحدث قبل قليل عن هذا
الموقف الامريكي وهذا التطور اللافت في
الموقف الامريكي في عقبه تطورات في
السودان طبعا
لانه ياتي سريعا بعد بضعه ايام من الامل
الامريكي يبدو ان هناك خيبه امل امريكيه
واضح الان في اطراف النزاع المتسارعه
المتسارعه الان في السودان سواء البرهان
من جهه الحكومه السودانيه او حميدتي
باعتباره قوه عسكريه على الارض يبدو ان
الولايات المتحده فقدت الامل الان في ان
تتمكن من اقناع الزعيمين بان يتوقفا عن
اسلوب العسكره والمواجهه العسكريه واللجوء
الى المفاوضات يبدو ان الامريكيين فقدوا
هذا الامل اعتمدوا لبضعه ايام على الموقف
العربي وكان هناك اتفاق جده تم اختراقه
واشتكى الامريكيون عبروا عن غضبهم وسخطهم
كان هناك محاولات افريقيه للمنظمه
الافريقيه ايضا هنا ايضا خيبه امل امريكيه
وربما حتى خيبه امل عربيه في المنطقه
وبالتالي الان الولايات المتحده وبعد
زياره وزير الخارجه في اوروبا مع الحلفاء
في النيتو لا شك ان التشاور كان السودان
جاء الان الرد الامريكي الذي يبدو الان
واضحا المنحه الامريكي الان بعد قليل في
اي لحظه الان في العاصمه الامريكيه سيتم
بالفعل حسب ما نفهم من المستشار الامن
القومي للرئيس بايدن سيتم اذا على مجموعه
من الخطوات من العقوبات كما يقول سلف في
بيانه نصدر اليوم عقوبات اقتصاصيه وفرده
قيود التاشيره ضد الجهات الفاعله التي
تكرس العنف واضح الامر هنا عن من يتحدث
البرهان من جهه حميد تيميجه اخرى والجيوش
التي تتبعهما والقوات العسكريه على الارض
العقوبات الامريكيه الان غير معروفه ربما
التاشيرات ربما تحويل ربما واقول ربما
تحويل شخصيه البرهان وشخصيه الى مجرم حرب
الى الزعماء حرب يتم متابعتهما قانون
قانونيا ودوليا لا يمكن التكهن الان بحجم
مدى شساعه هذه
العقوبات الى ان تعلن عنها لائحه العقوبات
والامكانات الامريكيه للعقاب هائله وكبيره
ويد الولايات المتحده طويله في هذا المجال
والسودان خبيره العقوبات الامريكيه في
السنوات الماضيه وسقط في ازمه سياسيه
واقتصاديه غير مسبوقه جزئيا بسبب تلك
العقوبات الامريكيه التي اقصت السودان من
المجتمع الدولي ومن اي دور دوري وبالتالي
الان الولايات المتحده تتحرك في اتجاه
العقوبات بسبب الاحباط الذي يصيب اداره
بايدن وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه التصريح
الامريكي قبل قليل جاء واضح المعالم اضافه
الى هذه العقوبات يقول والبيت الابيض في
هذه الحاله ان هذه الاجراءات يقول تهدف
الى محاسبه المسؤولين عن تقويض السلام
والامن والاستقرار في السودان ويقول ايضا
الشعب السوداني لم يطلب هذه الحرب سنواصل
الوقوف الى جانبه واضح جدا الان ان
الولايات المتحده تحمل القيادات القيادات
السودانيه البرهان من جهه بشكل خاص
مسؤوليه هذه الحرب وان فشلهما في اي حوار
سياسي فشل الحكومه البدنيه ادى الى ما ادى
اليه الولايات مضحكه
الولايات المتحده الى هذا الخيار الان مدى
عن فرض فرص ربما التفاوض او التباحث
التواصل والاتصال بالكيانات السودانيه
لتقريب وجهات النظر
وفرصه اخرى لهدنه جديده ربما تنجح هذه
المره
ياتي ايضا
القلق الامريكي ونوع من الغضب والاحباط
الامريكي في لهجه وزير الخارجيه قبل قليل
في السويد عندما قال اننا نريد بالفعل من
السودانيين من القيادات السودانيه ان تفهم
بالضبط ما نقصد وما نريد نحن في الولايات
المتحده ومعنا المجتمع الدولي وبالتالي
الاحباط من اراده القيادات العسكريه في
السودان يضاف اليه خيبه الامل في فشل
الجهود الاقليميه العربيه او الافريقيه
ادت بالولايات المتحده الى هذا المنطق
منطق في تفاصيل في هذه الفتره من هذا
الصراع لردع القياده العسكريه نعم تفاصيل
هذه التصريحات اذا ما فرضت هذه العقوبات
يعني المده الزمنيه ربما التي ستفرد فيها
هذه العقوبات اللي قريبه هل ستم فرضها على
الفور نود ان نعرف اكثر عن التفاصيل
المتعلقه في حال فرض عقوبات فعلا على
كيانات
اذا كان فهمي منطقيا ونعتمد هنا على هذا
البيان وبالكلمه يقول السيليفون في بيانه
قبل قليل من واشنطن نصدر اليوم اليوم بعد
ساعه بعد ساعتين بعد ثلاث ساعات ربما مع
نهايه هذا اليوم سيكون السودان سيكتشف
مسؤولون العسكريون في السودان حجمها
ونوعيه هذه العقوبات ومن ستستهدف وفي اي
اطار وبالتالي يجب ان ننتظر بعض الشيء كي
يعطي الجانب الامريكي خارطه خارطه الطريق
فيما يخص العقوبات وكيف يطبقها الجانب
الامريكي فقد الامل لان حتى اثناء تلك
العمليات وقف اطلاق النار الاتفاقيات لوقف
اطلاق النار اشتكى الامريكيون دائما ولم
يتوقفوا من الشكوى من القيادات العسكريه
السودانيه بانها كانت تنتهك عمليات وقف
اطلاق النار التي كانت تعيق حسب
الامريكيين دائما اعاقه وصول للمساعدات
الانسانيه وعمليه الاجلاء وشكلت خطرا في
بعض الاحيان على بعض المركبات الانسانيه
هنا هناك حتى ان بعض المركبات الامريكيه
تم استهدافها في الخرطوم قبل حوالي الشرط
تقريبا وبالتالي ادركها الامريكيون بسرعه
ان الجانب العقلاني او جانب العقل
والرزانه في هذه الحرب ليس دائما جاهزا
للتعامل مع الجانب الدبلوماسي ولذلك بدانا
نرى انه
بمجرد ان اكتشف الامريكيون ان الرغبه في
السلم ليست حاضره تم اصدار هذا البيان من
الذي يمكن اعتباره بيانا تحذيريا وشديدا
اللهجه في هذه اللحظه
نود ان نتابع ايضا التفاعلات في السودان
حول هذه القرارات الامريكيه والتصريحات
اللافته معك طاهر المرضي هل رشحت اي ردود
فعل من كلا الطرفين تتعلق بها التصريحات
الامريكيه
نعم حتى الان لم ترجع هي ردود فعل باعتبار
ان الكل هنا ينتظر ما طبيعه هذه العقوبات
الامريكيه التي تفرض على القوات المسلحه
او على الجيش السوداني او حتى على
القيادات ولكن بطبيعه الحال فقد حذرت جهات
عديده مع بدايه هذه الحرب وخاصه الجهات
السياسيه ومنظمات المجتمع المدني حذرت من
تدوين هذه الازمه والدعوه دائما الى
البقاء في البيت الافريقي لحلها لانها اذا
اصبحت لها تشعبات خارجيه ستكون الامور
اكثر تعقيدا كما انهم يقولون ان السودان
قد دخل في تجارب العقوبات في الوقت السابق
وجعل القيادات في الوقت الذي كان يحكم فيه
الرئيس عمر البشير اكثر تعنتا مما هو قبل
ان تفرض عليه العقوبات وبالتالي كانوا هم
يتخوفون من هذه المرحله اعتقد ان التل
بالعصا دون الجزره من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه سينقل الصراع في السودان الى
مرحله جديده وهذا التعبير بعدم التفاؤل
بان هذه الحرب ربما تكون بعيده الامد ولكن
الى اي مدى يمكن لهذه العقوبات ان تكون
لها دور الكبير في وقف هذا القتال خاصه
ونحن نتحدث عن يومين فقط من وقف او من
الهدنه التي وقعت في جده ذات الخمسه ايام
ولا معنى لعدد الايام طالما انه هنالك
انتهاكات لهذه الحرب بمعنى ان صباح هذا
اليوم كانت هنالك الحرب بالمدفعيه الثقيله
سواء كان في غرب ام درمان او في وسط
الخرطوم او جنوب الخرطوم او حتى في معسكر
طيبه خارج الخرطوم الجنوبا وكذلك نسمع
الاصوات الرصاص والانفجارات في مواقع اخرى
اذا الحرب الان اخذت تصاعد خاصه عن طريق
الاسلحه الثقيله واذا كانت هذه الهدنه قد
انتهت بالفعل فاذا ليس هنالك التزام من كل
من كل الطرفين فيما يختص بوقف اطلاق النار
ايضا هذا مؤشر هذه العقوبات الامريكيه
التي تلوح بها الاداره هو مؤشر على ان
البيت الافريقي قد فشل تماما في وقف هذه
الحرب خاصه وانه كان ينادي دائما الا تخرج
هذه الازمه السودانيه من البيت الافريقي
ولكن واضح ان الاداره الامريكيه الان
اصبحت متاكده الى درجه ما بان هذه الحرب
يمكن ان تتشعب وتخرج عن الطور الذي هي فيه
الان بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني ربما تدخل اطراف اخرى خاصه بعد
التحذيرات التي يعني وجهت الى عدد من
الدول وخاصه الجوار بعدم مساعده او تشجيع
اي طرفه منا الاطراف له الامر اعتقد ان
هذا الامر الان انعكس سلبا على الاوضاع
الانسانيه بشكل واضح وربما بعد نهايه هذه
الهدنه تكون الاوضاع اكثر جحيمًا في
اوساطه وفي مواقع التي تدور فيها
الاشتباكات اذا كان هذا هو المنطق الذي
تتحدث به الجهات المتصارعه في السودان
شكرا لا بدن اللا نقاش تعليق للمشاركه وان
المواجهه والحل العسكري سيكون هو العنوان
الابرز للمرحله القادمه من الخرطوم الطاهر
المرضي ومن واشنطن نصل الحسين شكرا جزيلا
لكما